[Music]
that song sound familiar yeah it's
dojicat's kiss me more an interesting
choice from noah schnapp following their
social media drama last week it's crazy
the 17 year old stranger thing starr
shared this tick tock on wednesday to
assure fans that things are all good
between him and doji even revealing that
he's since apologized for sharing their
private dms so how did we get here well
here's how things got turned a little
upside down
of course noah plays will buyers on
stranger things oh my god
oh my god and in season four they
welcomed a new character eddie munson
played by joseph quinn this year it's my
year
i can feel it yep it totally is his year
with millions of people around the world
becoming big joseph fans overnight
including doji who tweeted her feelings
a few times since watching joseph on the
spooky series
[Music]
so what's a girl to do well shoot your
shot dosia privately dm noah about
joseph only problem is noah shared
screenshots of their private chat on
tiktok he even captioned the post
thirsty doja i don't know it's since
been deleted but not before it was
viewed at least 20 million times and
doja yeah she wasn't too happy with noah
sharing their dms with the world the
fact that
this
person
that noah did that
like went and posted a private
conversation between me and him
is
so
unbelievably like socially unaware
and whack
and like you know what i mean like
that's like borderline snake
like that's like
that's like weasel
but now nearly a week later it seems
all's well between the two in noah's
latest tick-tock video set to dozia's
grammy-winning collab with sizza he
commented guys everything is all good i
apologized and i still follow her and
love her music no hard feelings and get
this the whole thing made sizable dents
in their follower counts doja lost 200
000 while noah gained two million it's
really cool meanwhile joseph his
popularity continues to skyrocket and
other good news flattery works with me
the breakout star has yet to comment
about the noah dozier situation but he's
busy getting love from his fans around
the world it's so lovely like the
the devotion that the fans have for the
show and kind of
um how they've found space in their
heart for a new character
um eddie is just so it's heartwarming
and um yeah
i don't know what to say about it it's
really they've been so gracious and
welcoming
it's lovely
[Music]
you